so my name is matt i have monkey pox
this sucks and you don't want it all
across social media monkey pox patients
are posting warnings this is a painful
debilitating disease that you don't want
to get i was in
so much pain right now the vast majority
of cases are in men who have sex with
other men it's rarely fatal but
activists in the gay community have
mobilized i'm very confident
that we can get ahead of it before the
massive outbreak
given
the community's
fortitude and their resilience and also
learning from
the
mistakes of covet and there is a vaccine
the cdc says it should be administered
in two doses 28 days apart but there's
not nearly enough of it
vaccination clinics like these are now
popping up across the country but
critics say the bind administration was
very slow at one point leaving hundreds
of thousands of doses of the vaccine
that the us already owns in europe so
now officials are trying to stretch the
vaccine by administering it in a
different way they're hoping to get five
doses out of one vial but there could be
a problem with that
it's totally unclear that anything i've
read on the science if the degree of
protection is identical
to what the original
proposal is or prescription which is to
get two full doses bob goldstraw says he
was turned away from getting his second
shot he believes it's a problem of
supply the d.c health department blames
the biden administration what we end up
getting is 12 000 doses had we got 12
000 vials of vaccine that would have
been some 60 000
doses that we would have had the monkey
pox virus has spread quickly in the
united states the first case was
reported in may the cdc says there are
now more than 14 thousand confirmed
cases the biden administration says they
are working to secure millions more
vaccine doses but health experts say
that creates other issues we need to be
partnering with our global
partners and colleagues around the world
to make sure that vaccines aren't just
made available to high-income countries
like the us and and and europe but also
that you know it's just it's pretty
alarming and disgusting that now there
are still no vaccines made available on
the continent of africa the maker of the
vaccine says it will take months to
expand its production capabilities but
experts say the window to contain a
broader outbreak could already be
closing
patti culhane al jazeera washington